well gentlemen congratulations the two
of you have succeeded and you are both
moving forward into third and final
round of our Double Trouble competition
in this last round we're going to be
sending you back to your home forges but
we're not going to be asking you to
build one iconic weapon from history
we're gonna ask you to make two
you will be building these
a pair
of kinunting swords
as one of the weapons issued to the
Philippine military special forces units
the gnunting swords have proven to be
effective and deadly weapons the word
genunting translates to scissors and the
inward curve of the blades design allows
for deeper Cuts while also proving the
user with a thin lightweight weapon when
paired together as a sword and Dagger
the longer sword serves its offensive
long-range weapon while the shortest
sword serves to be defensive post-water
weapon the intimidating dual swords are
built for brutal combat as well as
navigating thick jungle Terrain
well gentlemen you'll both have four
days to build your pair of gnutings one
of you is going to come back here and
leave ten thousand dollars richer
carrying the title of forging fire
Champion we will see you in four days
good luck
my name is Chris O'Brien I am 43 years
old ever since I was little I loved
creating things I loved making things
I'm actually an art major and when I ran
across the bladesmithing I was just like
that's something I need to try I'm gonna
finish forging out this blade and then
I'm going to forge up another Billet and
do the second blade and then that way I
can heat treat at the same time with
both blades we're almost there
all right we're about ready to hit it
that's the sound you want to hear right
there I decide I'm going to try a burn
through getting the tip just a little
hot
ah that looks good
buildings two swords this slowing me
down a little bit I'm still on track to
be able to finish with pretty good time
looking pretty good I like it I like it
all I have left to do is sharpen the
little blade and it'll be all done
[Music]
my name is Brian Salisbury I'm 60 years
old the reason I got into blade smithing
was I wanted a very particular knife for
my work I worked for the telephone
company so I made it and finally I just
said oh the heck with it I'll start
making knives it keeps me busy and out
of my wife's hair okay I got them forged
out the curves look good I got my tangs
in I've got to get these things in the
oil
and that way I know what I'm up against
tomorrow
so second one going in
all right let's see if she skates please
please please please please
not grabbing anywhere very nice
nice now I'm gonna drill the holes in it
we've got to finish up the last handle
and I am done very similar look to them
very happy
I gotta use these things
yeah that works
all right bleach Fitz welcome to the
Keel test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
I'm going to take your weapons and
deliver some slashes and throw us on
this big carcass around your first you
ready for this third up you mad dog I
will
foreign
[Music]
things here first off we're getting on
things they're a little bit on the
heavier side but that lends itself to
cut deep into the big carcass your
handle construction is smooth and it
gives me good retention and overall sir
you're getting on things
you will kill
all right Chris your attorneys are you
ready for this absolutely all right
let's do it
[Music]
all right Chris let's talk about you
doing things here
first up what I like about your weapon
here is the balance it's nicely
distributed the edges you have here are
sharp as you can see
pretty much cut a lot of this pig up
overall sir your genun things
you'll kill awesome
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
the bamboo chop to test the strength and
durability of your blades I'll be taking
your gnunting and chopping into our
bamboo Target here now remember this
isn't about what your conducting to do
to that Target but what that Target can
do to your gun hunting Brian you're up
first you ready yeah go ahead you ain't
got nothing else to do this afternoon
thank you
all right Brian first off they've got
some heft to them but they don't feel
bad they actually swing pretty good your
blade picked up
just a teeniest roll and then on the
smaller the two blades there's a again
it's just the smallest deflection other
than that they held up beautifully well
done
thank you very much
Chris you ready to play
sure
all right Chris right off
your handle design for me is just about
perfect as far as swinging these things
man they're super light the balance is
really nice on these I don't feel
anything on your Edge when I run my
fingernail up this thing no deflections
no rolls so good job thank you
all right please we know your blades can
kill and we know they're strong now it's
time to find out just how sharp your
blades are this is the sharpness test
the animal hide slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are I'm going to take your gnuntings and
I'm going to thrust and slash across
this animal hide Brian you're up first
you ready for this absolutely all right
let's do this
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Brian the edges you have here are sharp
every cut over there is quite clean no
Jagged edges and overall sir your weapon
you look up
thank you sir Chris your turn so you
ready yep all right let's do this
foreign
first up the grinds that you have here
are perfect for this kind of cut because
there is no resistance overall sir
you're getting things
you'll cut thank you
well gentlemen we had three tests we got
two Smiths but we can only have one
winner you guys both performed very well
but as you know only one of you can go
home the title of Forge and fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars the judges have made the
decision
in today's Fortune fire Champion is
Chris congratulations
Brian unfortunately your blade just
didn't make the cut Dave Baker's going
to tell you why Brian I think I can
speak for all of us when I say that
competitions like this are the ones we
love to see where Smiths bring back
weapons that are so closely matched this
came down to the smallest things Chris's
blade was a little bit sharper than
yours it didn't take any damage you did
a great job it's a beautiful blade
thank you
well Brian you're clearly a very
talented Smith and your work speaks for
itself on that but unfortunately your
time here has ended I'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the forge
floor
I put forth my best effort but it is
what it is you can't let it eat you up
too bad I wouldn't do a damn thing
differently I got matched up against an
absolutely excellent bladesmith this
time he came out on top we go again he
just might not
Chris congratulations you are today's
Forge and fire Champion you got yourself
a check for ten thousand dollars
my blades performed very well I thought
it would be awesome for my kids just to
prove to them that if you put yourself
out there and put the work in you can
accomplish what you're after my name is
Chris O'Brien and I am the forged and
fire champion